Honestly you're out of ideas, just play ROBLOX!
It's obvious pewds hasn't tried roblox
YOU SHOULD PLAY ROBLOX PEWDS,
THAT'S WHAT I CALL A GOOD GAME
PLAY ROBLOX PEWDS
IT'S THE GAME YOU'RE LOOKING FOOORRRR
pewdehpie pLAY ROBLOX
PLAY ROBLOX PLAY ROBLOX
PEWDS PLAY ROBLOX
ROBLOX BOI, PLAY ROBLOX
YOU FORGOT ROBLOX YOU PIECE OF CRAPPY--
NO!
No, I swore!
NEVER!
Never I will play that game...
Never in a million goddamn years... *Pewds Puberty Voice*
(distant) "Pewds if you play roblox I will donate you a hundred dollars" ?
Well, why don't you fucking say so? Hell yeah, we're playing-
We're playing Ro-
We're playing Roblox everyone! you could have started with that comment! Psch
Let's begin.
Our journey,
Through Roblox.
[INTENSE LIPS] autism simmilater
[LIPS INTENSIFY] 2017
I might not make it out alive,
My levels are still pretty high,
I could be overdosing.
I asked you guys on Twitter which ones I should play,
"[FIDGET SPINNERS] Adopt A Cute Family"
Upgrading Roblox...-
But how can you upgrade what is already perfection?
Is that-
Is that motherfucker wearing a Chanel sh-
T-Shirt?
Peh- Hahaha!
While doing a fidget spinner?
Hell yeah.
HELL YEAH.
This is my game.
"Choose your job."
well, they don't have youtubers,
So I'm gonna have to go with the...
The second closest one...
Wow.
INCREDIBLE.
*snicker and silent laugh*
haha..  Ahaha...
What is this fucking shit...
How do I go back up??
'Scuse me!
'Scuse me, can I get some- help?
Woah I'm back.
I'm back.
WHOA! She's got a fidget spinner!
Oh Mah
GOD!!!!
WHOA!
She's showing it off to me!
Can you fidget my spinner?
Aw come on.
god the screen is so fucking cluttered.
*OOF*
Did I just kill her with my-
WITH MY FIDGET SPINNER?
With great power...
Comes great...
fidget spinners
HELL YEAH!
This really seems like a really good game.
Oh wow.
Just a-
Good old Sunday drive.
Well, this is my car now.
"Stop in the name of the law"
*snickers* This is...
DEJA VU
WHOA Jesus Christ...
I think my car became a fidget spinner.
Oh my god,
I just killed a police officer.
But I'm just a fellow MC DONALDS worker
I'm sorry
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry...
THOT's get killed
*IS THE NEW WAY I LIKE TO BE-*
All right,
well...
THATS COOL.
I think it's time to move on...
"Counter Blox Roblox Offensive"
what-
what?
Whoa, holy sHIT!
This is just like Battlefield 2!
Oh my god is just like Battlefield!
what the fuck...
GOOOTTEM!
That's pretty fucking cool actually.
"DO NOT PLAY! WARNING SCARY"
Apparently the gamemodes are YouTube clickbait titles.
Wow!
INCREDIBLE
[what is this...]
Why the fucking syste-
I can't do anything!
Shut up!
JUST SHUT UP!
oh shit, I'm so scared guys
I'm so fucking scared.
oh god, I hope nothing comes down and kills me...
oh my god, I'm shitting myself
aAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
MAAHHH
THE WALLS GOT ME
I'm fine.
I'm fine...
WHOOF
Is that...?
What is that?
IS THAT AN AK-47?
I'm saved.
Slender
Is about to get a taste of his own medicine.
I'm joined by my army of bullets.
Just stay still I got 'em.
I'll get him for ya'
oh my...
THE BULLETS DON'T WORK
THEY DON'T WORK
aAHHH!
AAHHH
OHMYGODD
d'aahh!
What is this shit...
fidget spinners
Ro- bloxian
HIGHSCHOOL
Hey everyone,
It's PEWDIEPIE here!
with my-
Fidget spinner
Dananananana
Dananana nuh neh nah neh nuh
♪ Pewds serenading us ♪
This has to be the saddest point in my life.
This is actually more sad,
when I was in high school.
I managed to top myself.
I'm sitting alone in a cafeteria,
In Roblox,
WITH A GODDAMN FIDGET SPINNER
ＡＮＤ ＴＨＥＲＥ'Ｓ ＮＯ ＯＮＥ ＨＥＲＥ
Best game ever.
10/10.
So no-
*GAAASSSPPP*
YES- ES-
A  H O T  CHEERLEADER GIRL
W U T S  U P
She's looking at my fidget spinner.
She just jUMPED OVER IT
Well, It's still just like High School.
ooh...
Hello baby
Oh HELL- O BABY
WHERE YOU GOING BA-
I'm stu-
I'm fucking stuck
my fu-
god
Uh- Where're you...?
Come back, babe.
You want to fidget my spinner?
STOP JUMPING OVER IT YOU BITCH
Come back here!
you WILL,
fidget my spinner
bitch
*fast forward* Wait you can play as-
Vietnam in Roblox?
Hell yeah.
this is how the pros play it.
aaAAHHHHHHHH!
*battlecry intensifies*
*Laughs sadistically*
What up, dog? What up ah--shit?
Surprise motherfucka! AH SHIT. Well I'm back playing my favorite server, or you can abduct little kids, one moment.
I just need to figure some things out.
I think my arm is broken and shoulder is dis- Okay.We're flying now
okay, here we go
Get in
How do I drown him? Fuck I'm drowning.
[Evil laughter]
hahahahahaha no
Why is this so funny. [Robot voice] time for a rap battle. I'm not gonna Lie
this game makes me want makes me cry, but so just your mom when I
When I come in her eye ah what the fuck are you saying [hahaha]?
Rick
You're blue like a fish off shop. Fuck. [I] make you dish and
put you on my
Wife's playing Roblox is gay
Which it's okay, just kidding Roblox is gay drops mic
Fuck. I had more. I had more in me
What does fuck is this piece of shit game? Are you fucking kidding me?
Roblox isn't gay. Oh you fucking bitch. She voted me out [be] [cut] off you fucking bitch. Oh, it's like slither io
great
Get fucked bitch get Fucked bitch EVERYONE GET FUUUUCKED GET FUUUCKED
ROBLOOOX
ROOOBL I`m SHOOTING FIRE
~Tryharding intesifies~
Get Fuuucked, ha ha ha ha ha ha I dropped some new Merch
It's selling like a
[Jake Paul Voice] GOD CHURGE it's every day bro it's every day bro it's every day bro I said IT'S EVERY DAY BROOOOO //Pls stop this Jake is cancer
Jesus fucking Christ